(upbeat music)
- Hello.
- [Voiceover] Hey sweetheart,
we're on speakerphone.
- Oh, we're so excited
to see you this weekend.
- We're looking forward to it.
Brandon's excited too.
- [Voiceover] Oh, he can't
stop talking about it.
- Hey Brandon, aren't you excited buddy?
- [Brandon] Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- Remember when you broke my arm?
- Remember that time I
dared you to eat a candle?
Remember that time you always bottled up
your feelings?
- Remember that time you were an Abe?
Maybe you should cool it with the snacks.
- What the hell is that supposed to mean?
(footsteps)
- Has your sister gained a little weight?
- Hey!
No.
- [Voiceover] No, you're
gonna have kids one day.
You're gonna be going to PTA
and buying braces and you'll think,
wow, how did this happen?
It happens, believe me.
- Oh in 10 years honey you won't
have enough energy for children.
You want to do it now.
- Hey Brit, uh, Brandon.
- Brittany, Brandon.
- Hey Brittany, I mean, uh, Brandon.
How do I?
- Actually Brittany put that on here, so.
- She knows about it?
- Yeah, you're gonna wanna ask her.
- [Voiceover] I click I
click this square thing?
- Yes.
So remember the mouse?
This is the mouse, now.
- That's the mouse?
- This is the mouse, now.
Mom said you have to clean her bathroom.
- Did she say that
or did she tell you to?
- You're stupid.
What's so funny?
- Hmmm.
- Ugh, you're disgusting.
- Deal with it.
Our neighbors doing it again.
- Chip?
- [Brandon] Yeah.
- I hate that guy.
Your pores look weird today.
- [Voiceover] I just
want to say that you two
are the cutest couple.
- Oh, actually...
- [Brittany] Remember that
one time you drank a puddle?
- Yeah, you made me drink a puddle.
(laughs)
- That's what I just said.
(upbeat music)
Remember that time you told grandma
you hated her?
- Ow!
- Stay still.
- Yeah, 'cause grandma as
being a bitch that day.